uh more specifically kirk if i'm wrong
but you were mentioning something
oh yeah furries and things like
detecting furry yes is this true school
yes
schools protecting uh furries this
happened yeah i won't name the school
but this actually happened
uh and it's very similar to kind of the
the gender things as well um if you
if you are in if you're a teacher and
you don't you know refer to somebody
as their correct pronoun or now a furry
for example
uh you could be fired or you can be in
trouble suspended whatever it might be
for those that aren't familiar with what
if you guys all know what furries are
right
yeah but enlighten me so they're
basically people who
have some kind of that identify with
anthropomorphic cartoon animals so they
have what's called a fur sona
and oh we're we got buddha internet but
let's keep going they have what's called
the first sona
where they have a suit that they wear
that is a cartoon animal
and some people refer to them as like
fetishists others say it's just more of
an identity thing
but the reason i thought this was
interesting when you brought this up
before because i've talked about this
that
under the new york city human rights law
it does provide legal protection
legal protection to furries so people
who
want to wear a fursuit to work under the
law should be legally allowed to do it
the law states at least in new york uh
that gender identity is self-expression
and that you cannot be discriminated
discriminated against based on what you
wear
what you call yourself and for good rea
like for obvious reasons right if a
transgender person
is you know where if it's uh someone
born male and then
they they identify as female and they're
wearing a dress and they say their name
is susan
the idea is the business can't
discriminate against them based on those
characteristics
but then it opens the door for things
like furries and and i think the the
interest the thing about furries is that
it's interesting because it's a
recognizable
identity group of people that is i mean
they have they have conventions there's
a there's a lot of them
so you can't act like it's not real and
they're protected under these rules so
you know earlier before the show you
were mentioning something about how like
a school
there was like a teacher i guess who
didn't want to do it or something well
yeah
and i won't name it but yeah a teacher
was like i cannot believe that i
you know i could get in trouble because
i call this person by their name
and not by their you know furry fursona
fursona i don't know
so you could never hear what that is
until this particular
instant and it's this is happening
in a lot of different places this is
happening in states all across the
country
and well particularly more blue states
for
you know obvious reasons from a policy
perspective but this is happening a lot
and like and parents probably don't even
know
and then their kids have to deal with
the stuff at school i mean it's just so
it seems so bizarre to me i think there
may be a light light
at the end of the tunnel homeschool your
kids right
this is going to encourage more and more
parents to get out of the public school
system
everything the left has been doing has
been pushing this country in my opinion
closer towards and kapistan
where where defund the police okay we'll
hire private police
we're gonna we're gonna indoctrinate
your kids and your schools then we're
gonna create our own school pods and
pull our kids out
it's forcing families to basically
privatize things and
you have so many moms or parents that
were never even political at all but
then they see this stuff
infiltrating from a political
perspective and they're like wow i need
to get involved because this has gotten
to a point where it's
affecting me and my children and and
that really kind of wakes people up as
well i mean i hear this all the time on
the campaign trail
they're like i never followed politics
until this stuff was happening
uh and so there that is a silver lining
this is very stuff like
little kids that were sat down in front
of like teletubbies or like cartoons
with like a broken family
i think so i don't know about broken
family but i think if if someone
identifies with
anthropomorphic cartoon animals i have
to imagine that they spent a decent
amount of time as
as a child watching anthropomorphic
cartoon animals
and then built an identity around that
tiny toons
yeah if you're if looney tunes if you're
a little kid and you're not interacting
with adult human beings
and they're putting in front of a tv
where you're watching you know
berenstain bears and tiny tunes or
looney tunes or whatever
then you are seeing cartoon animals
talking and your brain is being wired
for that to be
adult society interesting so you build
this identity around
cartoon animals that talk and act like
people and then you get people who dress
up like that identify that way
if i played an age of empires as a kid
do i
do you might get to be like joan of arc
if age of empires as a kid you may end
up i don't know running for office to
become some kind of political
uh politician people just need to kids
need to come
like play more outside or something i
mean this has just gotten
i think strategy games are incredible
but not not the awful kind of jobs from
the industrial era era like hanging out
with your dad and and you know
watching him yeah like raising chickens
that's what i did yeah
you're the children should be watching
their parents work in capacity so that's
that's that's what i mean by jobs just
be like hey i'm gonna be building this
thing
come watch and i'll show you what i'm
saying kids should apprentice right yeah
yeah
that's what they used to do the kid
would watch the their parent do a
certain task and learn how to do it so
play outside
play strategy games and apprentice that
that's the key to parenting i think
there you go yeah
yeah as a non-parent that's the way i
would parent
kids want to be like adults so they're
looking up to adults and they're
emulating that behavior
if we put kids around a bunch of kids
they just emulate each other and then
they get their their behaviors from an
amalgamation of weird youtube videos and
and you know oh jesus yeah why aren't
the parents
saying parents are working both mom and
dad are at work oh yeah that's true
yeah but that's or they don't realize
how powerful
like media can warp a brain right
especially a young brain
yeah this is so interesting to me
because my family got static
because we were homeschooled and
everyone's like well they need to be
socialized
they need to be around other kids their
age and my parents were like no they're
around adults
you know adults will show them how to
speak and how to act and they don't
really need that influence and i did
wish that i had more friends but at the
same time i feel like i did mature
faster because i was around people who
already had this developed sense of self
and to me it was a net benefit because
it's like you need that positive
influence of adults in your life not
just other kids
yeah no i was homeschooled too and i
think for
high school i was not good in school at
all and it kind of goes back to you know
everybody trying to fit somebody into a
box i think all kids
really learn differently and school is
just not for me but then i was
homeschooled and i ended up
graduating a few years early and just
really thriving because
not only are you around kind of adults
but you're also able to kind of
understand
curriculum or you know almost read and
and
be outside of this kind of construct and
and the
complexities that come in a classroom
right that come with the classroom and
other kids and things like that so i'm a
huge proponent of
school choice especially in
homeschooling and
you know every kid should learn their
own way and um
yeah there's a social aspect of that but
so you went to public school in the
beginning yeah i did
i did i went to public school up until
about high school
and then did by choice did you leave no
yeah you know what i just
i didn't i never found
i don't know if i was challenged or it
was just a dif
i wasn't challenged enough um but i just
learned
differently and i i ended up
um homeschooling and then going to the
community college
uh back home and basically skipping
junior and senior senior year of college
and then going straight into um
university at miami ohio for a four-year
degree so
kind of did a a weird route if you could
do it again would you have homeschooled
the entire time or
do you think it helped that you spent
some time that's a good question
i don't know uh i would i think
probably up until elementary school i i
think public school is okay or like
being around other kids is
is fine um but then there gets to a
point where
you know all kids are learning
differently or at that time it was like
you're either put into you know higher
level classes or you're not or if you
were
a lot of it was i think it's
i guess in short i'm glad i did at least
by elementary school and a little bit of
middle school
in the pa in the public space but then
ultimately kind of where i needed to get
serious
and i needed to get into college and
needed to kind of
focus and thrive i was able to do that
by being outside of
homeschooled at a high school level you
use the internet a lot when you're
homeschooling yeah
definitely yeah it makes sense that's
the key man yeah it's a secret we we are
in the era where
uh you teach yourself yeah you become an
auto diet act right is that the the
project like i feel like i was such an
avid reader as a kid and like
always kind of wanted to explore other
topics and and i just did not
conform to this um
kind of uh just this the the
structure of public school and just what
they wanted to to
teach it just was not my thing but i did
they say nasty things about you where
your teachers like if you don't do this
you're going to end up working at
mcdonald's oh yeah absolutely
i was like it was crazy i was at i think
like a junior level reading
level and i was in like third grade or
something great like
and i only say that because in this
school and in some public schools you
have teachers that
they they look at kids and they're like
well you're not smart enough and you're
not that well
my test scores proved otherwise i just
wasn't
you know good at school i guess yeah and
um
and that really hurts self-esteem
because i knew i was smart but i just
never
uh but when you have p people telling
you that you're not fitting a mold or
you don't have teachers that are
encouraging you in a positive way
which i had great teachers but i also
had kind of bad ones like every kid
right
um and you can talk about this i'm sure
from a homeschool perspective
is when you have people at such a young
age like not encouraging you or not
wanting to
kind of one-on-one or help you from a
learning perspective and that's where
the parent comes in and my parents came
in they're like you know what you're
you're not doing great in school let's
tr we know that you're smart but let's
find a different avenue for you that's
where the parents have to take that
responsibility right
um but it does it does hurt your
self-esteem when you're a kid and
because they're like well you're
different from them i kind of had the
opposite
uh reaction when i was in school and i
would do well on tests but just not care
for the homework
just got more arrogant the more they
told me i was wrong i was like
you you so i remember i had one instance
in in math class when i was like in
seventh grade or something
and it was like a really stupid problem
like 30 minus 50.
and i was like dozing off not paying
attention to my teacher is like who can
answer this question and then she calls
on me thinking she got me
and i look at it i'm like negative 20.
and then i go back to like doodling
stick figures and then she demands she
demanded of me like what's the formula
and i was like formula for what like how
did you come to the answer
that you know 30 minus 50 is negative 20
and i was like
it's like three three minus five what do
you mean like it's just arithmetic like
did in my head
yeah and then i got in trouble i got
detention because of it and so i was
like this just proves these people are
morons because i can do it instantly and
they can't
i the biggest frustration of mine i
remember i was chewing gum in school i
think i was in middle school or
something
i was chewing gum and i forgot to spit
it out before getting into class
and i did it twice i guess in the same
week
my teacher deducted from my grade
because i was chewing gum and at that
point i was like this
is unacceptable you are a teacher you
are here to teach me the subject you are
not here to discipline me over
gum this is communism and i freaked out
i swear i was like
this is at that point i was probably in
middle school and i was like at this
point this is
un i'm like you my i'm being punished
from a grade perspective and because i
i was chewing gum how how hilarity is it
that how hilarious would it be to see
13 year old catalina screaming at the
teacher this is communism
telling me not to chew gum as communism
i love it no but it shows that deducting
your points
wasn't about your your skill or
abilities right it was about you being a
perfect little drone and doing as you're
told
exactly and then you know nobody that
everybody that did what they were told
got perfect grades that's communism
they'll pass you through school
i had a class in college that i never
attended i think i attended the first
day and then just stopped going i missed
the the midterm
test and they were like it's an
automatic failure i was like hey i went
in i talked to the guy i charmed him and
i was like
can i somehow do anything pl to pass
he's like if you can get an a
on the final i'll give you a d and pass
you so i studied i got an a on the final
and they passed me
totally against they just liked me it's
it's
i don't want to swear but that whole
system is rigged and jacked
in my opinion it's so easy to get
through it
if they like you and it's like you said
they'll just if you if you're arrogant
they just want to destroy you because
they're they're ego maniacs
and then think about the political stuff
sorry to interrupt you but think about
politics i was very outspoken as a kid
or as a college student at my school and
i had professors
that i would get bad grades because
i on a test if i didn't agree with them
and and i'll say that now and i'm proud
of it because i look at some
kids now and they're on campus and
they're like well i just i really want
to write
the right thing so that my professor
doesn't you know
fail me because i'm a conservative that
is a
huge problem that is a very bad problem
sounds sounds like these conservatives
are spineless or just kids
i'd rather have a d than ever
yeah i'd rather fail the problem is
they're spending all this money
to go there and if they disagree with
their professor and fail
then they've wasted their money
basically so they have to agree with
something they don't agree with
and and it's warping these kids into
crazy probably what's happening
yeah yep i'm so agitated today because
of this this shoving thing
school cuts off the tall grass if you
if you are young and talented they do
everything to hold you back and try and
stuff you in a box yeah
it moves at a specific pace if you're
not fast enough you get left behind if
you're too fast
you get pulled back yeah yeah well then
you're told that you're different
and then we think about i love for
example iron rand
and the fountainhead and a lot of her
books and you think about all these
entrepreneurs and people who weren't
good in school
and they you know do great things in the
world and
why aren't those people celebrated but
instead we need to protect
the structure of the public school
system and protect
everybody kind of is is the same uh i
think that's the detriment of
individuality
in a lot of ways yeah it it it's
communism public education is an
incredible boon
you know before we had it it was hard to
get education but now we don't need this
weird regiment
we have the internet and access to the
information so we can still
provide the boom i'll be honest man kids
should be
learning stuff way before five years old
oh yeah and so the idea that an american
kid is gonna like sit around watching
nothing but cartoons until five
and then go to school to learn the stuff
how horrible for a smart kid
yeah well aunt to make it also not to
bring up
um politics but to bring up politics
there was a school in illinois
and they had the worst percentage
of their kids were not reading and
writing i mean they had the worst test
scores
but that the biggest priority for them
was renaming the school they didn't want
it to be called thomas jefferson anymore
they wanted it to be called because of
the race relations and tearing down
statues and all that
that's what you're focused on when your
kids are at 11
reading at literacy rate against the
state
when did this happen this was recently
this was a couple months ago
middle school you know they were they
wanted at barack obama a
middle school but then people started um
he pushed back push back on that because
he didn't do enough for
her daca and immigration again
your school is failing it was in a
predominantly minority district
so people say well we're against you
know
why aren't you if you want to help
minorities then
you know help increase your literacy
rates
increase people being able to thrive and
get out of the system
whatever it might be hold on no no i'm
sorry
catalina that is racist the reason they
can't thrive it's not because they don't
know how to read
it's because of white supremacy right
it's very interesting
it's just so much easier should i teach
the kid to read or just point at ian
some people actually might think it is
because in the early 1800s when the
slavery system was there there were like
white people that had black slaves and
they were keeping them illiterate on
purpose because they wanted to keep them
disempowered
and unable to to migrate basically
they're just they're using all this
stuff as a scapegoat
because it wasn't that they were white
and black it didn't matter what their
races were they just happened to be
those people at that time
access to information is all over the
planet indeed access to information
and poverty like these are these are
major issues that
create injustice
right access to information like the la
the lack of i mean
like people who can't access the
internet uh or or who are not able to
learn the truth about what's going on
who have bad teachers or who are forced
to go to these institutions
learning facilities and they can't learn
people who have access to knowledge and
people who
are i mean poverty is connected to that
if you're poor you're
the likelihood that you're reading the
classics and powerful books and
philosophy is lower
according to democrats though you can't
even get a license if you're a minority
let alone access the internet so so
that's that's the opportunity thing
they think the opportunity doesn't exist
right
when quite literally it's it's an
outcome issue but the opportunity does
exist if people aren't doing it there's
personal choice involved you're making
me think about censorship and like this
whole censorship thing is
although they may think the ceos may
think they're doing something good by
keeping dangerous information away from
you they might
actually be punishing us because
sometimes you need to see
all sides of a situation mind conf is a
book people read it
and become more intelligent and
intellectual understanding the way a
psychopath may think
not necessarily emulating it right but
you must see the demon
to circumvent the demon and i i'm scared
that if we censor too much information
that we'll end up becoming whitewashed
and and basically fall prey to this
stuff when it does arise
it's like book burning i mean the books
being taken off of
the internet or you know whatever it
might be it's the same thing you're
who ultimately decides what is what is
wrong and what is
that is to be always the question is who
decides
what gets to stay and what gets censored
right
and the the point that we've been on the
show several times during the lockdown
people couldn't go to bars people
couldn't talk to each other but you
could go online the only problem is your
opinions were filtered through twitter
facebook and youtube so certain ideas
weren't allowed to propagate
right thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you